hello everyone my name is reto meier and
welcome to this week in Android
development for September 24 2012 last
week in Android developers live
stopwatch and timer apps with the target
of Android design in action hosted by
Anakin Adam live from New York and
London what happens when you apply the
holo theme to the skeuomorph a classic
hybrid stopwatch and timer check out the
video to find out last Thursday the path
of the space shuttle endeavour's final
flight took it almost directly above our
Mountain View studio while our
colleagues were out experiencing this
unique moment in space exploration
history you know I were here in the
studio broadcast in the premiere episode
of Android developers strike back our
stopwatch and timer app clinic patients
join us by a hangout to tell us exactly
what we could do with our helpful
feedback check out the video to learn
how much of it was anatomically possible
as usual we ran it off the week with our
review shows on the Friday games review
viewers wept as coke in was absent once
more and and gallons headwear was joined
by the inimitable E&E Lewis Esquire for
a review of the selection of games as
chosen by you then on the App clinic I
slipped on my thrift store skinny jeans
to put camera and photography apps to
the test with Ian who based on the
number of shows he co-hosted may or may
not be living out of our studio all of
last week's broadcast and all the
schedules for this week's shows are
available from Google developers live
those developers to google com such live
/ android if the end of quarter and our
team has objectives and key results to
achieve so there are eight shows
scheduled this week including a full
roster of office hours started with a dl
plus live from hong kong on tuesday
afternoon on Wednesday joined Nick and
rich for their weekly European office
hours live from London also on Wednesday
we've invited accessibility guru TV
Raman to join Trevor and Joe for a u.s.
office hours Q&A session on Thursday
Bruno will be hosting his bi-weekly
Portuguese language edition of Android
developers live Bruno assures us he's
talking about Android but for all I know
he could be offering cooking tips and
marital advice so if you speak
Portuguese tune in and let us know
exactly what Bruno's been broadcasting
Roman is back from his stay at the show
this week and will be joining Nick and
Adam for Android design in action this
tuesday at 1030am eastern time live from
the style capitals of New York and
London this week the guys are performing
an extreme makeover on flickreviewr
glimmer and classic camera replacement
app camera zoom FX find out what the
developers of these fine apps think
about their extreme makeovers on
Thursday when we invite them and the
other
camera app clinic patients to join us
develop a strike Mac join us live as
these developers tell us a little more
about their apps what they've got plan
and what we can do with our feedback in
the future I'm planning a holiday to
Hawaii later this year so we're holding
a travel planning and booking up clinic
at our new regular time of 1030am
Pacific this Friday use the moderator
page linked here to nominate the apps
you'll be using to plan your winter
escape this holiday season then a 12
joined Dan's hat and whoever sitting
underneath it for another episode of the
Friday games review wilco be able to pry
in from the co-hosts chair will dance
hat become self-aware and start hosting
the show itself tune in this Friday to
find out and hit up the moderator page
to nominate the games you'd like to see
us review in other Android development
news last week if you've used ADT to
create a new Android project you
probably notice the template options
available for deciding what type of you
I you'd like to start with if you ever
wanted to build your own application
templates we've now published formal
documentation zhan the template format
and syntax alongside the official
templates right in the android open
source project in you and updated apps
popular social productivity app do want
this week as did Bloomberg radio plus
providing with 24-hour live streaming
and on-demand listening for your finance
and economics reporting needs if you've
got a tablet the glue society presents
watch with mother an app that includes
six episodes of horror comedy for your
viewing pleasure in great news for news
fans the titans has launched a
tablet-optimized layout of their popular
news apps and finally for my aussie
compatriots if you're banking with ian
said the new app and zo money gives you
access to all your banking needs direct
from your mobile that's all for this
week in Android development my name is
reto Meier thanks for watching